it seemed like this tsunami of people
came in christmas night
it was probably the scariest experience
of my whole nursing career i do
understand people want to get together
you know and see their relatives this is
the result
medics speaking about what happened last
christmas when a wave of illness
suddenly hit the nhs
this year we're mostly vaccinated but
the new variant is causing uncertainty
could the tsunami happen again
here in windsor the general view is
let's wait and see
i think we've
got to live through it now
and just keep going
um so many people being vaccinated some
people had it
and just if you don't want to take the
risk to stay at home i'm not sure we're
meant to be going to my dad's but
whether we go
because he's he's high risk i don't know
that everyone's got to do the right
thing and just sort of
see who is important to see when it's
important to see them
are you worried that we're going to go
back into lockdown do you think that's
coming
i actually believe it's necessary
with the stats with the data that is
being published
and habits are changing shops on the
high street were hoping for the busiest
day of the year last saturday it didn't
come as a local little business i don't
know if you can survive this in that way
if there is so much uncertainty and it's
uncertainty that's killing your business
is it yes that's what it is people
people the customers they don't know
what to do we don't know what we are
doing we don't know how do we stock up
things
in the hospitality sector the impact of
uncertainty is even worse
one pub landlord here in windsor told me
he had 130 bookings for christmas but
only 40 have confirmed and despite
numerous emails 90 won't say whether
they're coming or not and that sums up
the frustration for businesses but also
the uncertainty that people are feeling
as we approach christmas
many are also scaling back their
pre-christmas arrangements as a
precaution but if like marcus they work
with the public they have to make tough
decisions
are you going to go see your family this
christmas so what what no mom lives with
my man and granddad's so that's why i
don't really want to chance it i mean
they're boosted and everything but it's
still
going to take that chance
on this day last year there were more
than double the number of covered
patients in hospital and 500 daily
deaths as opposed to 44 today
but in the last 24 hours there were over
90 000 new covered cases as opposed to
30 000 on this day last year and it's
that rising number that's causing
concern
which is why one wins a resident the
queen has just announced she's staying
put this christmas
jason farrell sky news